selon l'ADEME les bâtiments scolaires
représenteraient en moyenne 31% de la
consommation énergétique des communes
alors la ville de Tours a choisi de
construire sa toute première école en
bois et en paille l'école maternelle
Jean de La Fontaine à Tours Nord une
manière écologique d'isoler les
bâtiments le coût de la construction 8
millions 500.000 euros mais la commune
espère rentabiliser cet investissement
grâce aux économies d'énergie une
stratégie bienvenue en pleine période
d'inflation reportage de Sarah gros
structure et bardage en bois isolation
en paille adieu le bitume l'école
maternelle Jean de La Fontaine sera la
première de la ville à recourir à des
matériaux biosourcés on a cherché à
créer un bâtiment très vertueux pour
dans sa phase de construction et
également dans sa phase en fait
d'exploitation donc on a plutôt
travaillé sur une structure bois avec
une isolation paille donc très
performante d'une manière en fait
environnementale ce qui nous intéressait
également c'est peut-être pouvoir
travailler avec des entreprises locales
qui sont basées à une quarantaine de
kilomètres du chantier donc on
fonctionne également en fait en circuit
court grâce à son isolation optimale la
paille permet de limiter la
climatisation et le chauffage au gré des
saisons pour le maire de Tours ces
matériaux représentent l'avenir ce qui
est aujourd'hui une exception puisque
c'est la première école bois-pail de la
ville deviennent demain le standard et
donc ce type de construction on pourrait
la l'utiliser pour des bâtiments soit
des logements soit des bâtiments de
tertiaires de bureau donc on essaye à la
fois de suggérer ce type de construction
chez les promoteurs chez les
constructeurs un avis partagé même chez
les plus petits c'est mieux isolé si ça
fait des matériaux plus écologiques
c'est important pour toi
c'est important pour tous les enfants
quasiment qui sont dans cette école pour
notre avenir etc les portes de l'école
ouvriront en septembre 2024 d'autres
constructions de ce type restent à venir
le prochain bâtiment concerné sera une
école de commerce dans le quartier des
deux lions